ryan is with us in cleveland ohio hey
ryan how are you
hey sir how are you i'm great good how
can we help
got a quick question for you so i'm 24
years old out of cleveland ohio and
looking to purchase my first home and a
little worried because of how the market
is right now i kind of want to just ask
your opinion you know with interest
rates being so low it seems like if
you're not
the first offer and at least forty
thousand dollars uh over asking you
don't have a shot
so kind of want to ask your opinion on
that well i
i don't play those games i've bought
real estate my entire adult life
i own a bunch of real estate um i bought
a piece of real estate last week
but i did not uh i did not uh offer
more than asking price in order to get
it
uh i don't get it caught up in that um
my guess is you offered quite a bit
lower yes no on this particular course
actually yeah i want you to know how
dave
over on our last um house we looked at
and we lost it yeah well you didn't you
weren't supposed to get it it was a dumb
purchase
that's exactly right and i'm thankful i
didn't get it yeah don't don't purchase
something thirty five thousand dollars
over asking
i mean you're not desperate man you're
24. you got a long time
it'll be okay now the thing is this are
you out of debt
i i am yes sir i've got no college loans
grateful for my parents that were able
to uh pay the bill
for me to go to school i work through
school and i'm about two years into my
working career
good okay what do you make uh 65 000.
okay you're single
i am single but a girlfriend of six
years awesome
okay and you are uh not buying a house
with her you're buying a house by
yourself
it is yep it's gonna be under my name
and uh she'll also be helping to pay
the mortgage nope nope nope
don't sleep with your partner and it'll
just be on me don't sleep with your
partners
bad idea you'll get yourself in a mess
if you want to if you want to
if you want to do that it's time to get
married uh but no you're gonna get
yourself into a huge mess if you set
your life up based on something
uh based on a roommate situation uh so
no
if you're gonna buy you're gonna buy
based on your numbers or you're gonna
get married if we're gonna base it on
both numbers
because then you've got all kinds of
protection she has all kinds of
protection
she's not paying someone else's mortgage
on a home she doesn't own
i'm her dad right now i'm not going to
allow her to do that
that's a bad move for her okay
it will all be under me then yep all
right so you got your down payment and
you have an emergency fund right
yes sir i've got i've got money in the
bank and my other question too would
would it be smart to uh take advantage
of the fha or should i just do it
conventionally
conventional is the cheapest loan by far
a lot lot less expenses and you need a
good solid down payment 15-year fixed
where the payment's no more
than a fourth of your household
take-home pay
if you change your household by getting
married then you can recalculate that if
you don't then you're going to run it on
yours
now the deal is this there's a couple of
things
that cause people to get uh
goodbyes on anything real estate
included
number one is patience
if you get emotionally married to
something
you're gonna pay too much and it's dude
it's a stinking house
there's houses on every corner in
cleveland i've been there
there's a lot of houses in cleveland so
you don't need just
i gotta have this house you know when
you when you
when you get house fever like that you
need to go home take a cold shower
slow your butt down
slow slow
that's who gets the best buy it's the
second person that gets the next buy
next best buy is the person has the most
knowledge
so you learn the market you keep looking
at this neighborhood you're looking at
that neighborhood
you know the differences in them you
know the nuances you know the prices
over there
there's nothing in this neighborhood is
sold for more than 350 dollars a square
foot 250
a square foot 1250 a square foot
whatever it is
you know what it's going for and so
something comes on the market
that is uh you know you can look at the
numbers very quickly because you've
gathered information he with the most
information he with the most options
because you don't get emotionally
married to something and he with the
most
patience is the one who gets the best
buys
and a wise purchase slow your
butt down it needs to
in this market is hot white hot as it is
it may take you a year
to buy a house just enjoy the process
you're not dying paying a little rent
you're not gonna but don't go in there
and overpay
and it's just man i tell you what you
you smell like somebody's getting ready
to overpay because you got you're just
so freaking excited
he's in his early 20s he's in great
financial situations
the first house is the first house i get
why it's so exciting it is exciting
stacy and i bought a house uh two and a
half years in the marriage we ran in for
two and a half years
and we look back on that house now and
we go oh wasn't that cute
it's the first house it was nice it was
a good move for us we were patient but
it's the first house
and the other thing here and i'm not
trying to get in his relationship
business but
it's very interesting to me that he that
i don't know if he's talked to this girl
about this or not but he was under the
impression that she was going to pay
some of the mortgage
and they've been dating for six years
and i think i don't want people to miss
the relationship piece as to why you
were so quick to go
hey whoa whoa we're not going to do that
and that
you know six years we need to decide at
six years whether or not we're moving
forward or not
six years is plenty of time to decide
i'm the painter get off the ladder
yeah so why are we talking about going
into a co-mortgage situation with
someone you've been dating six years i
just think
that part of life has got to be figured
out first the first house will always
be there always slow down
slow down